en los vídeos anteriores hemos visto
distintas conformaciones del ciclo
hexano y que esencialmente lo podemos
pintar aquí como un un hexágono verdad
ahora este compuesto es mono cíclico y
cuando digo mono cíclico es justamente
esa idea que tenemos de que solo es un
anillo de carbonos ok ahora en la forma
oficial en la que you back' determina
cuántos anillos tiene un compuesto es
haciendo cortes por ejemplo si nosotros
hiciéramos el corte de éste de este
ciclo hexano entonces nos queda
esencialmente ya un arcano que no tiene
ciclos es decir este es un arcano
abierto es una cadena abierta qué
pasaría si por ejemplo tuviéramos un
ciclo hexano ok pero que esté digamos
fusionado en este sentido con un
1 de 4 carbonos digamos algo así que
digamos este sería como un ciclo butano
verdad entonces iupac determinaría que
si hacemos cortes podríamos ver cuántos
ciclos tiene esta molécula si hacemos
aquí este primer corte y hacemos este
segundo corte entonces ya tenemos un
arcano que es esencialmente una cadena
abierta verdad no tiene ciclos entonces
si si con dos cortes pudimos obtener un
arcano de digamos de cadena abierta
entonces decimos que este es un
compuesto bi cíclico es decir tiene dos
dos ciclos muy bien entonces vamos a
retomar este último ejemplo digamos
tenemos aquí en nuestro ciclo hexano
aunque ahí está nuestro ciclo hexano
lo fusionamos con este con este perdón
ciclo butano muy bien entonces algo
importante que hay que notar es que
estos átomos que digamos comparten que
están compartidos en ambos ciclos son
los los que se les conoce como carbonos
cabeza de puente son cabezas de puente
aunque cabeza de puente ok y estos son
importantes ahora para poder determinar
cuál va a ser el nombre o más bien la
nomenclatura para los compuestos be
cíclicos primero tenemos que saber
enumerar este compuesto y lo que vamos a
hacer es asignarle por ejemplo vamos a
tener que asignarle algún número alguno
de estos y seguir por la cadena más
larga que en este caso sería éste verdad
1 2 3 4 5 6 y luego nos seguimos por la
cadena más corta 7 8 y finalmente no
seguiríamos por la cadena que hubiera
entre estos 2
digamos cabezas de puente verdad
entonces ahí lo tienen está enumeración
y la siguiente o lo siguiente que hay
que hacer para poder darle nombre a esta
molécula es la siguiente vamos a poner
la fórmula digamos general de la
nomenclatura y en este caso pondremos
que es un biciclo verdad y vamos a poner
tres números equis que este primer
número va a ser la la longitud de la
cadena más larga o más bien el número de
carbonos en la cadena más larga
eliminando las cabezas de puente en el
segundo digamos en esta segunda posición
le vamos a poner la longitud o más bien
el número de carbonos de la segunda
cadena más larga verdad eliminando las
cabezas de puente y finalmente la
longitud de la cadena de la tercera
cadena más larga
que de hecho es la menos larga verdad
entonces ahí tenemos y finalmente
ponemos al can o el al canon al que se
refiere en este caso por ejemplo sería
un octano verdad entonces cómo quedaría
este ejemplo tendremos biciclo
primero ponemos el número de átomos de
carbono en la cadena más larga verdad
que serían en este caso 1 2 3 4 verdad
tenemos 4 en la cadena más larga luego
tendremos en la segunda que es 12 verdad
eliminando las cabezas y aquí tendremos
2 y finalmente cuántos carbonos hay en
la tercera cadena más larga pues tenemos
cero porque aquí en esta estructura de
puntos se ve justamente que no hay una
cadena entre estos dos verdad ahora
finalmente ponemos el nombre del arcano
correspondiente y hay ocho átomos de
carbono entonces esto es un octano muy
bien vamos a hacer otro ejemplo digamos
que tenemos ahora algo así tenemos este
mismo hexano ciclohexano aunque ya y lo
tienes
ok quizás debería corregir lo tienes
este ciclo hexano
finalmente vamos a ponerle algunas
digamos desviaciones digamos que de este
que va a ser una cabeza de puente salen
dos o más bien dos líneas es decir sale
un un átomo de carbono entonces tenemos
estos dos que son nuestra cabeza de
puente y esta molécula a veces se suele
se suele pintar digamos dándole una
estructura tridimensional digamos aquí
está nuestro nuestro ex ciclohexano
y ahí tienen el ciclo hexano y digamos
se le da una estructura tridimensional
se le pone digamos estás por encima
entonces estos dos estas cabezas de
puente que habíamos marcado corresponden
a estas y a veces es mucho más fácil
verlo
de esta forma entonces tenemos que
enumerar empezando con estas cabezas de
puente digamos da lo mismo si empezamos
aquí
en el otro extremo verdad ahora nos
seguimos por la cadena más larga
entonces sí nos vamos hacia la derecha
tendremos 1 2 3 si nos vamos por la
izquierda tendremos 1 2 3 así queda lo
mismo vamos a irnos por acá 2 3 4 luego
la segunda cadena 5 6 y finalmente 7
verdad ese sería nuestra tercera cadena
más larga ahora qué es lo que tenemos
podemos ver que si nosotros eliminamos
este de aquí que y quizás debimos
haberlo hecho antes de hacer la
enumeración podemos ver que si quitamos
2 2 ya tenemos un compuesto o más bien
un arcano que no tiene ciclos es decir
es una cadena abierta
podemos garantizar que esté este que
hemos pintado aquí es un compuesto be
cíclico verdad entonces el nombre será
biciclo verdad y ponemos primero el
número de la cadena más larga quitando
los dos las las cabezas de puente
entonces tenemos dos verdad 1 y 2
déjenme marcarlos aquí quizás podrían
marcarlos aquí 1 y 2 ahora cuál sigue el
número de átomos de carbono que se
encuentran en la segunda cadena más
larga y tenemos dos verdad y finalmente
podemos contar el número de carbonos que
hay en la tercera cadena más larga y
podemos ver que es una verdad entonces
tenemos el biciclo 2 2 1 y tenemos 7
átomos de carbono entonces esto es un
ept a no finalmente esto es un biciclo 2
2 1 están muy bien y de hecho esta es
una molécula que aparece mucho en la
naturaleza y por eso tiene un nombre
común que se le conoce como noor bora no
muy bien insisto este es una molécula
muy común es muy común en la naturaleza
y por eso es mejor ponerle un nombre
particular a este muy bien vamos a hacer
un ejemplo más que sea similar al caso
anterior que teníamos pero digamos que
tenemos algo así ok
algo así
es muy parecido digamos al caso anterior
que ahí lo tienen
finalmente unimos y ahora le damos esta
estructura tridimensional que íbamos a
poner algunos grupos sustituye entes
aquí muy bien vamos a seleccionar lo
íbamos a copiarlo para que veamos cómo
pueden funcionar las distintas
enumeración es que le podemos dar a esta
molécula entonces
ubicamos primero las cabezas de puentes
son justamente justamente estas y
tenemos dos formas de numerar lo por
ejemplo podríamos dar el número uno aquí
o podríamos dar el número uno aquí
verdad en el caso de la derecha si
hacemos esto hacia donde tendremos que
denominar pues tenemos que seguir la
cadena más larga que sería hacia la
derecha verdad entonces tenemos 2 3 4 y
5 luego no seguimos con la cadena la
segunda cadena más larga si nos fuéramos
por arriba sería de longitud 2 si nos
fuéramos por acá tiene longitud 3 verdad
entonces tenemos 6
y finalmente terminamos con el de arriba
que es 8 verdad ahí está la enumeración
si lo hiciéramos del otro lado pues
tendríamos que enumerar en este sentido
tres cuatro cinco seis siete y ocho muy
bien entonces la pregunta es cuál de
estos es el correcto y recordemos que
tenemos que buscar el número más bajo en
donde aparezcan los grupos sustituye
entes verdad entonces por ejemplo en el
caso de la derecha el grupo sustituyen
te aparece en el carbono 8 y en el
carbono 7 mientras que en el de la
izquierda aparece también en el carbono
8 pero en el carbono 6 entonces nos
damos cuenta que la enumeración de la
derecha no es la correcta porque el
digamos el primer grupo sustituye ente
en el caso de la izquierda aparece en el
6 mientras que en el de la derecha
aparece en el 7 muy bien entonces nos
quedamos simplemente con esta
enumeración y podemos simplemente ver
que tenemos grupos y metales unidos al
carbono 6 y el perdón 6 y 8 entonces
tenemos
8 dimetil
dimetil y este es un compuesto bi
cíclico verdad entonces esto es un
biciclo y vamos a ver ponemos el número
de átomos en la cadena más larga sin las
cabezas y en este caso sería 3 verdad
tendríamos 1 perdón 1 2 y 3 luego
ponemos el número de átomos en la
segunda cadena más larga que en este
caso serían 2 verdad y finalmente en la
tercera cadena más larga tenemos 1
verdad tenemos 1 y así es como pudimos
asignarle este nombre ahora cuántos
átomos tiene esta estructura pues tiene
8 y por lo tanto se le conoce como
octano este es un octano muy bien
entonces finalmente ya podemos concluir
que el nombre completo de esta molécula
es el 68 dimetil biciclo 321 octano